welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the Nemesis of
spoiler free reviewers and this episode
were breaking down the secret ending of
Resident Evil 3 the remake differs from
the original in many ways and even has a
special secret ending that sets up
several sequels throughout this video
we'll be going over the full part of the
game its eventual ending and some leaks
on Resident Evil 8 there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to play through the game yet and
don't want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day and if you
enjoy them please drop a thumbs up
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into a breakdown of
Resident Evil 3 okay so from the off the
game feels like kill Jill directed by
Quentin Tarantino nemesis is relentless
appoints and the guy really needs to
learn about social distancing because
god damn in the opening of the game he
attacks Jill in her apartment during the
Raccoon City outbreak and stalks her
evolving over time into a bigger and
better beast unlike the original there's
only one ending for the game so don't
worry about the choices you make though
you can get one where Nikolaj wins he
even throws a knife through Jill's head
maybe this should have sent him after
Jill because this guy sucks anyway the
basic plot is quite simple with Jill
teaming up with a group of umbrella
forces known as the u BCS that were
originally brought in to help people
evacuate however there is a special
agent within the group that has secret
orders to cover up the entire operation
collect data on the experiments and
destroy the vaccine that is Nicolai Jill
races through the city with the help of
you BCS members Carlos and Tyrell and
she even gets infected herself however
that Carlos manages to gain a vaccine
and the two discover a secret umbrella
facility in the basement of a hospital
that is packed with tyrants and hunters
Tyrell tells her that there's an
incoming missile strike but that they
have a ride out of there if they manage
to get a vaccine
Jill manages to manufacture this but
nikolai takes it from her jill is forced
to fight the nemesis whilst carlos
chases
they collide down but she defeats the
creature by using a gigantic railgun
that would make Metal Gear Rex blush Gel
makes it to the rendezvous point where
she discovers a conquest Carlos and
Nicolai appears with a vaccine which he
then destroys both Nicolai and umbrella
want the missile strike to go ahead as
it will completely cover up the outbreak
Jill was a survivor of the Spencer
mansion outbreak and she was threatening
to unearth the secrets that umbrella had
hidden this is why they sent the nemesis
after her and it's clear that the
corporation wanted to hide all of their
dirty doings Nicolai was absolutely
loving this and it really becomes a
massive antagonist for Jill to go off
against health at gunpoint it seems like
jill has no way out of it however call
us Rises and with help from GLA managed
to wound Nikolai and they escaped in the
helicopter whilst the city's eradicated
I don't know why they didn't need the
vaccine to board the helicopter like
Tyrell said but hey who knows anyway
unfortunately unlike the original Barry
Burton isn't the pilot of the ride but
on the chopper Jill and call us make a
promise that is to take down umbrella
even though they don't have any evidence
as the labs and creatures were all
destroyed they still dedicate themselves
to bring down the company now going
forward I definitely think that this
will be a main storyline in the upcoming
games after the credits we are treated
to a brief scene in which we see an
unknown character with a broken vaccine
vial though this isn't confirmed I think
it's a pretty safe assumption to make
that this is Jill and that she's keeping
the vial as a reminder of the events
throughout the game umbrella proved time
and time again that they were more
interested in money than they were human
life this was exemplified in Nikolai who
openly bragged about how he valued money
above saving people in the city and Jill
must take them down I never really
understood umbrellas plans because if
they make everyone a zombie then who do
they sell that stuff to but never mind
that's mainly in the movies anyway this
symbol of the broken vial to me
metaphorically shows how all the proof
that Jill had has been blown apart these
two contained the cure for the virus and
therefore this shattered symbol of it
reminds us that hope is bleak for Jill
and Carlos but they're not out of it yet
you may remember at the end
Resident Evil 2 now Claire and Leon made
a similar promise and they vowed to take
umbrella down once and for all
I am gonna have to clarify something
about Resident Evil eight and nine later
in the video but for the moment when I'm
discussing the future game I'll just be
referring to it as Resident Evil 8 going
forward I think that in Resident Evil 8
we will finally see the two pairs team
up and join forces in order to bring an
end to the corporation if this was
always the plan to drop Resident Evil
with these characters in it and it makes
a lot of sense to also put out the
remakes back-to-back to remind us of
their stories and plight how do you
think they are pulling this all together
for a big game going forward and the two
endings being quite similar
definitely cement that for me now before
we get into the news we have on Resident
Evil 8 I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the Star Wars
Skywalker saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the game in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and this up be shipped out from the end
whoever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone who takes part ok so this
morning on the 4th of April Twitter
account aesthetic gamer drop the
following tweets when discussing
Resident Evil 8 ok so the little game is
done this will be breaking this month
with more details later not by myself
but I've needed to clear some stuff up
Resident Evil 2021 is Resident Evil 8
but it wasn't always Resident Evil 8
during most of its development that
existed is revelations 3 the reason I
said re 8 was the ads away earlier this
year as last year re 8 was in
development and that one is years away
but a Capcom didn't want a huge gap
between re 7 and re 8 so that title got
pushed to the side for now and internal
testing and such was super positive on
Rev 3 revelations 3 was received a lot
better by testers internally etc than
they expected so the game is being given
an additional year in the oven to
convert itself to hari 8 the Ambassador
leaks about werewolves and Ethan in a
snowy village or 100% true but they're
outdated info
the game has been going through some
huge changes to make a more mainline
title big changes to the story
characters etc so specifically what
you've heard may not be fully true in
the final but a number of elements
remain the same so as I've said it's a
cross-gen game that should be revealed
within the next few months it is first
person and many purists are going to
hate it because it's taking some serious
departures in the story / enemies and
the like hallucinations occultism
and sanity and not being able to trust
others are huge thematics of the game
the rest I'll leave to be revealed later
this month but the game I am incredibly
excited about and I think knows weary
should be open-minded most who played
the game near finished his rev3 think
it's terrific it'll probably be a high
quality game but I do know the original
idea was it was going to be revealed at
e3 but of course that's not happening
now so there's a lot to unpack from that
and it sounds like they're taking
massive diversions from what the game
series has been so far now it does sound
like Resident Evil 8 is now going to be
Resident Evil 9 and revelations 3 is
instead going to be renamed as Resident
Evil 8 so though I have said the
characters will be reappearing for that
game it is a bit confusing to talk about
but I think it will more lean towards
them being in Resident Evil 9 and
perhaps things being set up in Resident
Evil 8 the mention of occult elements
makes a lot of sense as these have
already appeared in Resident Evil 4 and
7 however here it sounds like they're
leaning a lot more into it obviously
there are a lot of changes here and
whilst I would probably prefer a
third-person adventure moving the
perspective the first person has been
set before and does seem legitimate the
entirety of Resident Evil 7 was of
course in first person and even the
opening of Resident Evil 3 2 contained a
first person element
it sounds like umbrella are mixed up in
some really bad things and going ahead
whether it's in Resident Evil 9 think it
does make sense for Leon clad Jill and
call us the team up to take them down
Resident Evil 7 also featured the return
of Chris Redfield for the finale and I
think that the pieces are slowly falling
into place to bring the main leads of
the series together for one more
showdown who knows we may even get some
returning
castmembers searches sherry Birkin and
the enigmatic ADA one there's a ton of
things to look forward to and after
completing the Resident Evil three
remake in a day I have to say I'm still
as invested in the series now as it was
back when I first played it in the 90s
Resident Evil just has something about
it and as long as they keep making
quality games in the main series I'm
definitely interested in jumping back in
overall I had a blast with the game and
though I wish that nemesis hadn't
evolved so quickly I have to say that it
was a relentless ride from start to
finish I think it's the perfect sequel
to Resident Evil 2 and now they are set
in this same scenario have similar
controls and the idea of escaping from a
giant monster they do differ in many
ways Resident Evil 2 was a slower paced
game that relied more on its atmosphere
and tension
whereas 3 is just non-stop action I
probably prefer to at the moment but the
fact that are pretty much sat and played
through the new game in one sitting
shows how invested I was it always gave
me a reason to keep playing and that
opening half-hour is absolutely
incredible as a Resident Evil fan I
couldn't be happier as these last two
games have been incredible and I really
can't wait to see what's coming next
time if you love action horror games you
need to play this and though I think
some elements could have been improved
upon it's still an awesome ride overall
resident evil 3 is packed and it gets an
8 out of 10 now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the game and what
you took from the ending of it comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of Zack Snyder's original 5
film plan for the DC EU we go over all
of the films in the outline and discuss
what would have happened in them too so
it's definitely worth checking out even
if you only have a passing interest you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you get access to content early if
you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at Definition YT
or click the discord link in the
description below that was the best ways
to keep up to date with heavy spoilers
so hopefully we see over there very soon
[Music]